the strongest Demon Slayer in history
was yorichi tsugikuni a man who lived
nearly 500 years before the beginning of
the story he is the one who invented
breathing Styles and his style was the
original breath of the sun all the other
breathing styles are just derivatives of
the original in fact yorichi attempted
to teach Sun breathing to other demon
Slayers but they just weren't as strong
and as capable as he was so they could
never Master the original style as a
result yorichi modified the breath of
the sun to fit their own unique
abilities and that is how the other
breathing Styles emerged yorichi is the
only human that moves on is truly afraid
of because he came very close to killing
muzon and muzon was forced to run away
from him subscribe to anime uproar right
now for more Demon Slayer content